Mick Baron
Long spined sea urchins.
These things eat everything. From an area that's absolutely rich with kelp and
forest and down in
the deeper waters,
it's like an asphalt driveway.
There's nothing on it.
There's no kelp.
There's no periwinkles.
There's no shellfish, there's no crabs, there's nothing.
They spread their larvae.
They breed in August, September, which is our coldest time.
Going back 30, 40 years ago
it was just a degree, half a degree too cold for their larvae to
survive.
They hadn't made it down this far. But that one degree temperature change is
enough to allow these animals’ larvae to survive.
That's really what's driving it.
They have predicted in another two to three years, over 30% of the east coast of
Tasmania could very well be urchin barren.
This is the cost,
this is the cost of climate change.
Believe it or not. It's happened, right?